it is so wonderful to see you sean and
dylan i just watched the film last night
i'm still absorbing everything that i
watch and it is just
a beautiful story that you brought
together and congratulations to both of
you
and sean this project has been
he gave her a book 15 years ago and she
brings jennifer to life on screen i mean
as a director what does it mean for you
to see her embody jennifer
really i i think that whenever you walk
onto a set as a director
and an actor you know really comes to
the plate
as dylan did here it's moving
because you know clearly you had an
attraction to the material
a vision of what it could be and then
to see that that force whoever that
leading actor is going to be in this
case dylan
um you know i i remember feeling the
same thing
working with jack nicholson just feeling
so grateful
when there was that kind of investment
brought to something
and and dylan had that and it was so
exciting i think
to all of us and then you know all the
creative
uh parts and pieces of what you get to
be challenged with together each day
um who better to work with than somebody
you want to be around
you want to be around dylan that's good
and i think dylan wants to be around you
as well
because your performance dylan is
outstanding i
i don't know if i should just clap for
you i don't think just amazing
and i understand that you pulled from
your own experience to bring the
strength and struggles of jennifer
what was the hardest part for you to
watch
oh the entire thing i really don't
like watching myself um
but it's but it's at the same time i
love this story
and it isn't my story it's jennifer's
but yeah watching
self-act is real cringe-worthy for me
what does your mom think
my mom yeah what did she do oh
i mean i think she was really moved by
it i think um
she knew she knew the story as well and
um
i mean this is the first time she's
really seen me
act so you know she was a
proud mother she's a proud mom
and that's what it is like even though
this is a heavy story to see you guys on
screen together
this relationship of a father and
daughter sean this must be one of the
most
joyous moments for you to create a
project like this no question
no question about it and just to see her
her shine her talent shine um
you know and and and uh listen i'm
grateful to any
talent that offers themselves up to the
rest of us
to to engage with and the idea that my
daughter is so
on the map with this is thrilling
i love that and the fact is this is your
sixth feature film that you're directing
it's been 30 years since you've been
doing
the last film you did what's the next
project for you what do you want to work
on
well i i would have to consider
seriously if this one is directing a
movie and she throws a script down it's
kind of
you see vice versa i love it
congratulations to both of you and i
can't wait for everyone to see this film
as a mother watching this film was very
very hard especially seeing catherine
take on patty and uh brilliant so
congratulations to both of you seriously
thank you so much
thank you
you